[Music]
Erin and Eric we have been playing apex
legends for now three days I'm liking it
more and more personally but I know you
Erin I feel like you're at your you're
not on board and there is you put it
very well and it's what I had happened
to me was like when I went to the event
last week it very much was an emotional
roller coaster as far as how I initially
was extremely bummed out I said this is
to death I like fine titanfall to like
just phenomenal and innovative as far as
the shooters go and that's what I think
everyone has been dying to see is a
third game but this is not that and it's
just been up and down so past three days
have been playing with my heart yeah
because like there was a surprise
announcement that there's gonna be a
titanfall game and then we realized it
wasn't gonna be a titanfall game and
then in that first day it was no we're
not working on titanfall 3 so it seemed
like this game this battle royale game
had killed the titanfall the titanfall
series in a way that you know like
blackout didn't cook didn't kill Call of
Duty and firestorm isn't gonna kill
battlefield
I mean battlefield might kill
battlefield the firestorm didn't do it I
think I mean that's the thing is I think
people there was there are so many
articles and Knicks messaging around
what is happening with titanfall as a
franchise and I think people are jumping
the gun on this I don't think at all is
respawn killing titanfall
I think what they are doing is
financially I think they need a win and
I also I think it's two things I think
one titanfall 2 and probably one didn't
make them a lot of money both games are
critically acclaimed right but like they
did not get a lot out of that and it's
been known and I think that this game
kind of came out of that I also think
that if they were to make another title
3 and do what titanfall 2 did
it could be another failure right like
as far as like they need to like Ted
step back from that game I feel like I
mean to be to be fair to titanfall Titan
vol 2 in particular it was like a really
beloved game and it got sandwiched in
between Call of Duty and Battlefield 4
like someone just made that decision
arbitrarily so that game was not
released during a good window and it's
like I questioned like I get that they
feel like sales weren't good for that
game but I feel like if it been a month
earlier two months earlier the game
would have done way better but that
being said like yeah putting out Apex
Legends for free it's it's smart like it
from a business standpoint smart and
since this game came out it was like an
EI earnings call where they said yeah
like we're making some titanfall premium
thing later this year and Zampella
teased it we don't know what it is but
like fair or not it's like a lot of
people felt disappointed that this
wasn't titanfall it didn't have wall
running in Titans and they had thought
that this game had killed their like
beloved franchise and now it's not so
clear like we're back to somewhere in
the middle where they might still have a
titanfall this year or like maybe next
console generation but as long as it's
something is still existing I guess I as
the person that barely touched titanfall
2 at least and from reading a lot of the
stuff that has come out I don't actually
think this game killed off titanfall 3
like nothing has indicated that now
there's a lot of saltiness from the
community because for you guys that you
know enjoyed and loved titanfall 2 you
wanted a third you know iteration right
and you know instead you're kind of like
oh well I guess I just got left with
apex legends but I think you wouldn't
want to told me they've been working on
this game since like 2017 or something
like that so it's yeah it's been a while
right like almost right away after like
Tydfil launch they said spring 2017 so
that's very like close right after like
titanfall was like essentially out - -
that is and if this is true it didn't
sound like this was like you know and
taking the the remnants of a titanfall 3
like they created this game out of like
what they had done with time fall -
which was they you know they call in the
action boxes which is they were just
messing around
and taking ideas first opposed to like
having a full fleshed battle royale game
battle royale they said like they saw
pub G not fortnight which is interesting
that it was like pub G and they're like
looks let's see how that works and they
like we're messing around and end up
being really fun this is all like
internally they were messing around with
a battle royale game and then they came
to the terms like let's ship it and
again this is the if they've said this
to death to is that this was all respawn
this wasn't like EA this was their
choice this was like their choice to
like again like I feel like they just
needed a win
[Music]
I think the other cool thing too as I
had mentioned to you early on the stream
is and we have to give a credit to them
is that a facts legend is a like
full-fledged like game that is out that
you can play that is not like we are
still in beta or like this is a not
finished game like you have to give them
credit for that and I think it does
enough to kind of like change how battle
Royales go you know like we are we we
know how battle rails play out you know
like and there are still those game
mechanics in the game but like I feel
like it is more squad based you have
abilities and we are only slowly now
trying to figure out like what's a good
team what like how do we take advantage
of these things and I think some of that
is what's fun you know like and coming
from there pedigreed like the shooting
still great you guys know the guns so
I'm having a lot of fun I'm at left foot
too and like this is a good example I
think of like something that's unique
where you know like when you're trying
to like argue with what is the
difference what makes this game stand
out and it's like I think it's moment
like moments like this where it's the
game has slowly kind of like been
trickling out like surprises in a way
like oh you can do that so essentially
like it's been this is on our stream
it's Eric me and then and then
essentially is it like found a way to
zipline up onto the sled rage dinosaur
bone pile yeah like I didn't know you
could get up there and so we just have
this advantage where now we're just like
watching other squads like battle each
other and like we have such a clear
advantage like just sniping people so
this is pretty cool so you unfortunately
got killed got a little greedy if it
well it's because I for whatever reason
couldn't take the zip line up where I
was screwing something up where like his
zip line was there and but there was
like already one on the map going the
other way and every time I was going up
it would like pull me on to the other
one so I was actually like down to the
left you can see my name there trying to
snipe from an angle and it kind of
worked out for the most part because one
guy finally came and killed me while I
was trying to snipe people but couldn't
save you that's all right but you guy
told you guys not to - you guys had a
tactical advantage
and I would have never thought that you
could have gotten out there right but
it's something that it's a character
that Ben's been playing a lot yeah so
Pathfinder this Pathfinder robot this
guy pox is all here which is like
distract riding to distract us with
different clones but I didn't know this
is that mean rise just like he goes
cloak oh that's interesting you go cloak
that's what it is in this situation I
thought that you are supposed to like
act like Mirage pick one of them yeah I
thought you're supposed to like pretend
like you're you know you're potentially
a clone or fake decoy and but he there
he is Club close and we like took him
out but this was really cool it was like
we're up here and this is the fence
parties and so the circles closing in
and it's we have to get down there and
we see what we thought was just one
person in this place and so it just felt
so badass because we had been and we
were able to do this which is
essentially like set up as a zipline and
we thought we had the upper hand so he
came down which is kind of part of the
hero ability system yeah it does it's
like shines pretty well but what we
didn't know was that there was a second
person coming in here so and I didn't
make it clear that was going in the back
doors we both went in the back door what
what what just happened there did we
just go in together and and she killed
both of us people are liking it like
they're liking the class-based system
and they are enjoying the mechanics that
are there I mean respawn is is known for
taking something that's good and making
it better so how do you feel I mean you
said your opinions changed over the last
three days if you'll respawn in
titanfall side how do you feel respawn
is doing in the Battle Royale genre
I think the abilities are like are just
offering different ways of playing and
they're changing up the flow of game
like you could argue that like the
characters here were what I thought was
so brilliant about tiny ball 2 which was
with how they took characters and put
them in just the Titans where you are
recognizing someone on the field and you
are now thinking ahead of as far as what
they are able to do in a situation and
the more you play the more that that
kind of gets utilized that part of the
brain is
thinking ahead and knowing how to handle
situations and learning from them I
guess I kind of knew that going in like
again from last week I saw that but now
having three days of like playing that
and erasing that over and over again
that's fulfilling my progression or my
end game itch that I was afraid that I
would fall off quicker or it's like all
this cosmetic stuff I don't give a [ __ ]
about it but like this is what's kind of
getting me excited to see people
experimenting with that stuff I think
the other thing that's more interesting
to me or kind of shocking in a ways we
know there's a battle pass coming right
and we know traditionally battle passes
for battle Royales are pretty successful
right it gives the players a reason to
kind of like log in try these different
challenges some are harder than others
you know but eventually as you work
through it you're getting stuff right
and this game is littered with banners
and skins and gun skins and I kind of
wish the battle pass was here even next
week because I think it's not so March
right like maybe give people a week to
feel it out and playing and then like
next weeks like alright cool here's your
battle pass right because they do still
need to make money this game is
free-to-play
you don't need PS Plus and I'm not sure
about Xbox Live Gold some some people
said yes I'll let commenters tell us if
we do or not but they need a way to make
like actual money right battle passes
are pretty like straight forward you
know what you're getting it's like
here's a dollar a week would you pay a
dollar a week I would right and the
other thing too that I think from a
battle royale perspective that they've
done well is the pinging system
I think the ping system is actually like
very great for communicating like
different things like hey let's go here
oh there's an enemy there oh I need
health ping the health I haven't seen
any other battles really take advantage
of that it's super cool games in general
like I don't know the other game that
does it so well like that also we're
just when you walk up to items the
amount of information it gives you like
if you want to pick it up or not I think
is a bit above and beyond
yeah the way other battle warrior games
handle that yeah it's really easy to
understand what it is that you're
looking at and if you need it or not
yeah I think also another point to be
said about this game and you made me
think about upon like realizing like
again like this was under wraps for what
two years and came out swinging
with like a super polished Battle Royale
game that is that as we can agree like
has innovated a diorama for sure in
different ways the other thing too is
like what's it at I think it's eight
hours a million people playing you think
about respondents studio and you know
we're kind of in our own bubble and you
could even say like the titanfall
community everyone knows that series is
phenomenal but they don't have know
people playing clearly if there were
enough people playing them we would have
had a time full three if they were to do
another titanfall 3 it could have been
like another case of that game not doing
well and then you would have your
franchise dead I think here and even in
the subretinal entire fallout some
guideposts it's like hey I know nothing
about titanfall but I played apex
legends first and heard about basically
the shitstorm going on this Everett and
Here I am and I just eyelid titanfall 2
to give it a shot like in a way this is
already like this is a studio like
sending out their feelers like just
essentially saying like alright let's
just get our talent out there and like
start pulling in new people and make
some money and then come back when we're
ready and have an awesome titanfall 3
and to that point
you know they can always expand modes
like the four night which is the leader
right now they just constantly cycle
modes and weapons all the time
challenges all the time you know people
who like titanfall might not like a
slower-paced battle royale but if they
start cycling modes and cycling other
things in this game that that are more
than just let's be honest there's a lot
of hiking in Battle Royale
it's kind of the opposite of like trying
to get a Titan to fall out of the sky
and wall running yeah so if that battle
paths in march starts making things a
bit more interesting and maybe they
start talking about new modes this could
grow into something more than just a
single mode which is totally battle
royale it kind of is just a single mode
yeah yeah that's also kind of my concern
though like I think a lot of people are
having fun in the now in the moment it's
free-to-play you can tell all your
friends to hop on with you and you guys
can enjoy it right but that was my fear
with the lack of the battle pass who
knows what other modes may or may not
come I could also easily see it being
like a quick like that was really fun
for a couple weeks and then I fall off
you know kind of like blackout almost
right like we're back
a little bit too and they've done small
things like oh we added the boat is
there now and you can drop in this other
area but they haven't really won they
haven't really done the battle pass I
don't think and - they haven't really
like added any like modes like that are
that enticing the play so my fear is
what is the what is the longevity of
this game and I think you're right and I
think you know in comparison to black
out the upper hand here is rolling out a
new legend a new character that will
bring me back compared to what black out
be doing a new map a new area a new
weapon I mean black that's how they
don't anything
well like four times yeah even now right
like meanwhile for Knights holding
marshmallow concerts and like it still
feels like four nights a game that's
kind of chasing where the ball is going
and everybody else is chasing the ball
and I'm curious like Reese well in the
great studio I'm curious that they can
be one of those people who can figure
out where the ball is going and like get
people engaged in that way I'm not
saying let's see concerts but just
something and and they can pull off the
titanfall universe
thinking about last night like it is
worth acknowledging like the
frustrations that people have like I get
it I'm also bummed that you know it's
not another time fall game but I think
when you look at the bigger picture of
like that studio and what they need I
think this is a win and I think like
they should be proud of this game I
really I really don't really think that
I'm happy to like wait another couple
years for titanfall like think of think
about like a new console launching with
an innovative titanfall 3 I would rather
have that than titanfall 3 right now
like I can wait it's not the titanfall
game that I want but as you pointed out
earlier if it raises enough excitement
for the titanfall universe and like ends
up with a great titanfall 3 at some
point in the future in a player base
going in like then I'm all for that
that's cool yeah for sure I'm just gonna
play apex legends become legend - no I'm
gonna become a champion become champion
they just call me I don't know it's like
a year in apex legend when you win you
should become a legend right legend
anyway
[Music]
you